well you know i felt like  a part of  me  uh i could see that in being as far as  what happened with what's happening with  ben when i was in orlando it was some  similar things happening  now  um i just didn't like the fact that  whatever was going on on the inside had  to be made public knowledge  now obviously i'm there with ben a lot  he's one of my closest friends so i was  upset just to hear all the things that  was being said about him  and you know i just was like man  instead of saying it publicly just  address this person behind closed doors  and so now it doesn't look so bad  when we played the hawks and we lost i  was upset at being on that play  i wanted him to dunk the ball tattle rim  down  but he didn't do it  and it wasn't just his fault that we  lost that series so my thing was we  can't just blame him